el rectángulo abs de esta graficado en
el plano coordinado los siguientes son
los vértices del rectángulo dadas estas
coordenadas cuál es la longitud del lado
a d del rectángulo entonces bueno vamos
a graficar lo esta sería una manera de
atacar el problema así que se nos están
dando las coordenadas de los vértices
primero vamos a enfocarnos en la primera
coordenada dibujo mis ejes este es el
eje de las 10 y este es el eje de las x
así que me voy a enfocar en los puntos
aire porque sólo me están pidiendo que
encuentre la longitud desde el punto a
hasta el punto d así que bueno el punto
ba está ubicado en x igual a 7 y la 1
entonces tenemos 12
4 5 6 7 esto es x
7 y igual a 1 así que bueno este es el
punto y ahora dónde está el punto d el
punto d tiene exactamente la misma
coordenada x que a pero su coordenada ya
está un poco más arriba su coordenada y
es igual a 6 entonces estas cinco
unidades más arriba que la coordenada
lleve a así que el punto de está ubicado
en x igual a 7 y la 6
entonces es 123456 esto es igual a 6 por
lo tanto tenemos que el vértice de que
está en 7.6 el vértice b está justo aquí
y podemos conectarnos con una línea si
así lo queremos para mostrar que esto es
un lado del rectángulo así que bueno lo
voy a dibujar
ahí está ahí quedó y observa que ni
siquiera he dibujado todo el rectángulo
porque sólo con graficar estos dos
puntos podemos podemos ya responder a lo
que se nos pide queremos saber qué tan
largo es el lado adbe entonces
averigüemos lo la coordenada x no cambia
de a de pero en la dirección vertical si
crece por cinco unidades vamos de igual
a uno allí igual a seis entonces nuestro
cambio en jeff es 5 y eso responde la
pregunta cuál es la longitud del
segmento a d es 5 fuimos del punto 7.1
puntos 76 ahora recuerda que nos dijeron
que esto es un rectángulo y bueno para
completar esto vamos a dibujar el
rectángulo completo porque no entonces
tenemos al punto b en x igual a 5 y 1
ahí está el punto b ahora esto de
dibujar el rectángulo completo solamente
lo estoy haciendo por diversión porque
ya terminamos el problema solamente
queríamos encontrar la longitud del lado
a d
pero bueno x igual a 5 igual a 1 ahí
está el punto b
es el punto 51 el punto c está en x 5 y
6 aquí está el punto c x igual a 5 llegó
a la 6 y por último vamos a conectar
todos los puntos claramente podemos ver
que tenemos un rectángulo conecto 6
conectó c y b y conectó veía
pero queríamos saber cuánto mide lado a
d bueno pues sabemos que mide 5 entonces
este lado mide 5 este lado mide 2
unidades el de arriba también mide 2
unidades por ser paralelo a él y este
lado mide 5 por ser paralelo al lado ade
el cual va de 7,1 a 7.6 entonces mide 5
unidades y terminamos